- The functions y is equal to eight
times 3/4 to the x power,
and y is equal to 1/8
times 7/4 to the x power
are graphed in the xy-plane.
Which of the following statements
accurately describes whether each function
is always increasing or decreasing?
So let's look at each of these functions.
So this first function right over here,
let's see, as x increases, what happens?
Well as x increases, we're
going to multiply by 3/4.
We're going to raise 3/4 to
higher and higher powers.
And every time you multiply by 3/4,
you're actually going
to decrease its value.
Let's just draw a little table here.
So if this is x, and if this is y,
when x is zero, well 3/4
to the zero is just one.
And then y is just going
to be equal to eight.
When x is one, it's going to be
eight times 3/4 to the first power.
When x is two, it's going to be
eight times 3/4 times 3/4.
When x is three, it's going to be
eight times 3/4 times 3/4 times 3/4.
And every time you multiply by 3/4,
you're going to get a smaller number.
If I take 3/4 of something,
you're going to get a smaller value.
So as x increases, y is decreasing.
So this right over here
is a decreasing function.
Now what about this one over here?
Y is equal to 1/8 times
7/4 to the x power?
Well here as x increases,
you're going to multiply by
7/4 more and more and more.
And so when you multiply by 7/4,
7/4 is greater than one.
Increasing powers of 7/4
will make the entire value larger.
It doesn't matter that you
started with a lower value.
As x increases, y is going to become
larger and larger and larger.
So this is an increasing function.
And the way these functions are defined,
you can have more than just
whole number or integer values of x,
but these are good,
these are indicative ways
to just think about well
what happens as x increases.
So as x increases, y increases.
Here, as x increases, y decreases.
So the graphs of both functions
are always increasing? Nope.
That's not right.
The graphs of both functions
are always decreasing? Nope.
This one's decreasing,
this one's increasing.
The graph of y is equal to
eight times 3/4 to the x
is always increasing? Nope.
That one's decreasing.
The graph of y is equal to
eight times 3/4 to the x
is always decreasing.
That's right.
As x increases, as you move
to the right on the x axis,
your y value is going to get
smaller and smaller and smaller.
And the graph of y is equal
to 1/8 times 7/4 to the x
is always increasing.
That's right.
As x increases, you're going
higher and higher powers of 7/4,
and the more you multiply by 7/4,
the larger your overall
value's going to get,
because 7/4 is larger than one.
So this one is right.